our Kelly is due back in court this
Thursday on his most serious charges yet
he now faces 11 new counts of sexual
assault and abuse the R&B star denies
all of the charges in an exclusive CTM
interview back in March he insisted that
he has done nothing wrong
[Music]
nearly 20 years ago music critic Jim de
Regatas helped break the first story on
claims against our Kelly in his new book
it's called solace the case against our
Kelly he says he knows of 48 women who
were allegedly abused by the singer over
30 years our Kelly's attorney told us
this quote I have not read his book nor
do I care what he says we will worry
about the court and not mr. de Regatas
Jim de Regatas joins us at the table to
discuss good morning really good to have
you here I go I was fascinated by your
book because I'm thinking I've heard
about this this this is this but for you
that started around Thanksgiving 2000
you can get a fax you even bought a copy
of the fax you've got a fax and you get
a fax at your job and it says what what
do you do with it it I throw it on the
slush pile of hate mail and press
releases that I'm gonna ignore because
any time I wrote about hip-hop that's
not music it's noise or if I dared
criticize the Rolling Stones or a baby
boom icon but there was a tone in that
fax dear mr. godith Lehrer goddess I'm
writing to you hoping you can help
Robert has a problem
his problem is young girls yeah I slept
on at that holiday weekend and I went
back to I added science I went in the
office once a week to get my mail file
expenses and leave you know before the
editors could give me more work as pop
music critic and there was a level of
specificity at a young woman named
Tiffany Hawkins who it alleged had filed
a lawsuit for having a sexual contact
with Kelly
at age 15 he picked her up in her choir
class at Kenwood Academy many years
later though Jim we are still talking
about these kind of allegations yes and
20 years later he is
will not gone to jail right why every
system in Chicago has failed dozens of
young black women Gail the courts the
churches the schools journalism the
music industry yeah you know it was me
and another reporter abdun palish at a
brilliant columnist who's a hero of mine
Mary Mitchell and that was it
for until recent months really everybody
wanted to dismiss these charges because
and I'm only echoing what dozens of
young black girls have told me for 19
years nobody matters less in our society
than young black girls you right Jim
that you say I put the number of people
who knew about or witnessed that damage
in the thousands in the thousands from
record company publicists and tape
operators to Clive kölner the president
of jive records you know
Barry Weiss you know Reverend Jesse
Jackson one of his spiritual champion
they deny that they know Barry Weiss's
listen I'm running a record company he
drive records was named in lawsuits
filed by underage girls and if you're
being sued as a party on a ten million
dollar lawsuit by a fifteen year old
girl you know you said you mean you you
heard people for years they would say or
Kelly likes them young it was it was
it's the worst fact it sounds like I per
believe when I say this Gail but if you
go to Chicago on the south and west side
and you talk to two or you took to three
black women to will have stories not not
that they've been but them or their
sister or their aunt or their cousin or
their mom has been at Kenwood Academy or
the Evergreen Plaza shopping mall or the
rock and roll McDonald's when Kelly was
cruising back to Anthony's point they
say young girls they don't call him a
pedophile they just think he has a
problem and he needs to get help even
the women who are with him don't seem to
be mad at him they just think we just
need to help this guy the hate that's
coming my way your way and most
troubling Lee the way of the young women
who have accused him the social media
hatred it's just a lie the most common
statement I've heard in 19 years of
reporting this story his brother needs
help
brothers got to stop Jim our Kelley's
attorneys say you have agenda
you're not just doing reporting my
throttle conclusion here your response
I've sat with 48 women who've done the
most difficult thing a woman can do to
tear out her soul and talk about their
sexual assault to a stranger and put
their name on it and go public and then
be vilified as a liar of gold digger you
know for that I mean that is courage
this book is about the girls this book
is not about this man he goes to court
Thursday do you have any reason to think
that it's gonna be different when he
goes to court
I believe the state of Illinois case
will be torn apart because it's about
three victims who are cooperating one
who isn't and I believe the federal
indictments are coming within a month a
pattern of 30 years of sex trafficking
obstruction of justice tax evasion the
FBI the Department of Homeland Security
and the IRS is after him and they have
interviewed Gail everybody in my book I
mean they are spread out okay very
thorough I will say that do you want to
really write that our Kelly denies it
Jim dear goddess thank you very much
solace is on sale today